Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, heute mal ganz live auf Funkwelle FM. Das ist noch eine etwas ungewohnte Situation, sowohl für mich als auch besonders für die Hörer, die diese Sendung dann später als Podcast hören, aber auch die, die jetzt schon live im Internet dabei ist, weil sie dabei sind, so wie das normalerweise läuft, hier bei Chaosradio Express. Das ist jetzt hier eine Sonderausgabe, eine von Vieren. Ich werde hier in den nächsten Wochen, jeweils am Sonntag von 15 Uhr bis 17 Uhr, den Chaosradio Express in den UKW-Raum tragen, denn normalerweise gibt es uns nur auf dem Internet. Chaosradio Express ist ein Podcast, und zwar ein Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club. So eine Art Ergänzungsprogramm zum Chaos Radio, was eine Sendung ist, die schon sehr, sehr lange läuft in Berlin auf UKW, allerdings nicht hier im freien Radio, sondern bei Fritz im öffentlichen Rundfunk. Einmal im Monat ist Chaosradio dran und Chaosradio Express, da wir hier volle Freiheit haben, wenn wir irgendwas aufnehmen und senden, kommt halt mal ab und zu und mal häufiger und dann mal wieder nicht. Wie das immer so ist, und jetzt muss ich mich selber erstmal an die Regelmäßigkeit gewöhnen, von vier Sendungen jeweils eine pro Woche. Tatsächlich gedenke ich auch noch, ein bisschen Podcast dazwischen zu schmeißen. Wer also Chaosradio Express noch nicht kennt und jetzt hier über Funkwell FM das erste Mal dazu stößt, der sei mal auf unsere Webseite hingewiesen chaosradio.ccc.de. Das ist unser Podcast-Portal. Da gibt es ein großes Archiv aller Sendungen, die bisher gelaufen sind. Na, sagen wir mal fast alle. Ein paar ganz alte Chaosradio-Sendungen haben wir leider nicht wieder gefunden. Aber Chaosradio Express ist komplett archiviert und heute ist bereits die 91. Sendung am Start. Ja, und wie das immer so ist beim Express, gibt es einen Themenschwerpunkt und dazu einen oder zwei oder drei Gäste auch manchmal. In der Regel ist es einer und so soll es auch heute sein. Und ich begrüße schon mal hier Gregor. Sag mal was, Gregor.
Hallo Tim.
Ah, so, ich bin bester Hoffnung, dass du auch überall zu hören bist. Ja, mein Hausphilosoph ist da. Und wir möchten ein Thema ergründen, von dem ich zugegebenermaßen keine Ahnung habe. Oder wahrscheinlich wird mir Gregor gerade gleich mal ausführlich darlegen, dass ich eigentlich alles darüber weiß, es bloß noch nie unter diesem Begriff abgespeichert habe. Habe ich recht?
Ich wünsche es dir.
Sonst wird es unglaublich peinlich. Aber das macht mir gar nichts. Ich bin auf Peinlichkeiten eingestellt.
Als Hausphilosoph ist man auch in einer gefährlichen Nähe zum Haus- und Hof-Naden.
Das stimmt, aber das ist eigentlich meine Rolle. Wir sind jetzt sozusagen der Nahe und der Philosoph.
Und wo ist der König?
Der König wird noch gesucht.
Das sind unsere Zuhörer.
Der Kunde ist König. Das hast du schön gesagt. Tja, jetzt müssen wir erstmal einen Einstieg finden. Habe ich denn schon alles gesagt? Angenommen, du würdest Chaosradio Express nicht kennen. Wusstest du jetzt, was Sache ist?
Ja.
Wirklich? Man kann auch erwähnen, dass wir auch immer schön streamen, wenn es live ist. Wir haben unser eigenes Streaming-Network unter streams.xenim.de. Das ist sehr zu empfehlen. Das findet sich alles auf unserer Webseite. Ich kann euch auch nochmal auf unser Blog verweisen, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Da kann man dann auch zur Sendung diskutieren. So, jetzt soll es aber mal reichen hier mit der ganzen Einsteigerei. Das haben wir hier schon mit Musik eine Viertelstunde verschlammt.
Fangen wir doch gleich an. Das ist als Hausphilosoph, bin ich ja schon mehrmals dann hier gewesen und deswegen haben wir uns auch öfter schon mal unterhalten, was könnte man denn so machen, weil wir hatten ja Spaß bei den bisherigen Sendungen.
Wir sollten ruhig noch mal drauf hinweisen, was wir schon gemacht haben. Also unser Einstieg, unser gemeinsamer hier bei Chaosradio Express war...
Perirodan.
Die größte Science-Fiction-Serie der Welt.
Genau, in die du auch sehr viel Einblick hast, wir haben so viele Themen und das war auch eine sehr interessante Sendung. Kann ich euch nur empfehlen, wer sich mit dem Thema schon immer auseinandersetzen wollte, kann man alles nachhören im Internet. Und dann hatten wir neulich eine sehr nette Gesprächsrunde, wo ich leider total müde war, aber es machte nicht viel, weil ihr beide, also du und Christian Heller, ihr wart fleißig am diskutieren und ich musste nur ab und zu mal die Hand heben.
Genau, da ging es um futurologische oder futuristische Aspekte, anlässlich des CCC-Kongress-Mottos, Cyberpunk, Steampunk.
Offiziell stand Volldampf voraus und man musste dann immer so ein bisschen herleiten, was damit eigentlich gemeint war. Es war etwas schwierig, sagen wir es mal so. Aber wie auch immer, das Ganze stand unter dem komplizierten Titel Retro-Futurismus, was auch so ein Klumpatsch-Wort ist, wo man nicht so richtig weiß, was ist denn das jetzt?
Genau, da hake ich jetzt mal ein. Weil Retro-Futurismus war schon so ein bisschen so was wie die Postmoderne in der Science-Fiction. Und aus dieser damals recht interessanten Diskussion kam dann bei mir die Idee, jetzt haben wir das schon drüber gesprochen, aber eigentlich fehlt jetzt mal so eine Sendung, auch im Chaosradio, zu den theoretischen Grundlagen, also zum Big Picture, zum Thema Postmoderne. Und dann kam mir noch die Idee, dass man das verknüpfen könnte mit 40 Jahre 1968. Und da hättest du gesagt, da hättest du sowieso schon was in der Mache. Und das war quasi 30 Jahre Gründungsmeeting des Chaos Computer Clubs. Was jetzt blöd klingt, warum das eine 40 Jahre, das andere 30 Jahre. Aber das Lustige ist, dass dieses Gründungstreffen im Zusammenhang stand mit einem zehnjährigen Revival oder wieder Treffens nach 68. Also 78 haben sich ganz viele Leute getroffen und haben quasi im Anlass von zehn Jahren seit 1968 sich in Berlin versammelt zum sogenannten Tunix-Kongress. Und bei diesem Tunix-Kongress, das wusste ich sogar noch aus der Zeit, weil das ein großes Ereignis war, man mir davon erzählt hatte, dass dort ein Philosoph aufgetreten ist, nämlich Michael Foucault. Und dieser Michael Foucault ist ein postmoderner Philosoph, oder wird in jedem Fall so gesehen. Und da habe ich gedacht, jetzt könnte man das mal zusammenführen, so ein aktuelles Jubiläum, dass wir aber ein bisschen anders aufziehen, weil der Chaosradio Express sollte ja nicht unbedingt die Information jetzt nochmal aufwärmen, die schon überall herumgeistern. Und da hatte ich dann dieses Thema vorgestellt unter dem Titel Poststrukturalismus. Und Poststrukturalismus ist quasi das Theorie-Netzwerk, oder die Philosophie zur Postmoderne.
Die Philosophie zur Postmoderne?
Ja, präziser kann ich das nicht sagen.
Sozusagen der offizielle Snack der WM?
Nee, mehr so im Sinne von McDonalds, die inoffizielle Nahrungssponsor der Fußballfans der deutschen Nationalmannschaft. Also eine Engführung, das wird sich schon zeigen, ist nicht möglich. Das eiert auch immer ein bisschen herum.
Eine Einführung ist nicht möglich?
Eine Engführung.
Eine Engführung, was ist denn bitte eine Engführung?
Eine Engführung ist, dass du sagst, Poststrukturalismus ist das Denken unter den Bedingungen der Postmoderne. So ein apodiktisches...
So ist es.
So ist es, das widerstrebt der gesamten Denken, das dahinter steht, weil dieses Denken will gerade diese apodiktischen Zusammenhänge auflösen.
Das heißt, es ist sozusagen eine Weitführung.
Ja.
Man führt die Dinge bewusst in die Breite und lässt sich nicht so sehr auf eine Sache festnageln.
Unbedingt. Man will gerne so ein Pudding sein, den doch andere möglichst gegen die Pfand nagen.
Du musst nicht festnageln lassen. Klingt erst mal so ein bisschen weicheierisch.
Genau, das ist... Und da kommt quasi mein Interesse an dem Thema auch gerade in diesem Zusammenhang mit dem Chaosradio Express Thema mit reinzubringen, weil so weich das alles klingt, es gibt harte Evidenzen, dass da was passiert ist. Dass da was passiert ist, was man als postmoderne bezeichnen kann. Und das hat aufzeitbare Spuren in unserer Kultur hinterlassen. Und ich finde, das ist nicht bewusst genug. Insbesondere in unserer Generation. Und insbesondere in dem Milieu, das so durch die Hacker-Kultur dargestellt wird. Es gibt Ansätze, dass auch zum Beispiel beim Konferenzprogramm vom Chaos-Kongress, das hin und wieder auch mal mit anzubringen. Aber es fehlt aus meiner Sicht der Versuch einer theoretischen Fundierung. Vielleicht können wir das heute leisten.
Das ist natürlich unser Ansatz. Vor allem ist es jetzt erstmal der Versuch einer theoretischen Fundierung meiner selbst. Und dann muss ich jetzt nochmal einsteigen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Poststrukturalismus, das ist irgendwie der Snack-Regel, der Postmoderne. Was ist denn die Postmoderne?
Die Postmoderne ist eine Distanzierung. Also Menschen haben in Betrachtung der Geschichte Epochenbegriffe eingeführt. Und ich denke mal, in so einem alltagssprachlichen Bewusstsein sind wir aufgewachsen im Sinne von Charlie Chaplin, Modern Times. Wir leben in modernen Zeiten. Und es hat auch uns niemand gesagt, in unserer Schulzeit oder auch in der Zeit danach.
Ich bin übrigens mit Mon Onkel aufgewachsen. Hänst du den auch, den Film?
Der von Tati. Jack Tati? Ist das der, wo er auch auf diesen Messen sich herumtreibt?
Das ist glaube ich mehr die Hülo-Serie. Mon Onkel ist ja der großartige Film, wo er der Onkel der Familie, die halt voll diese Moderne lebt, mit automatischem Springbrunnen, der eingeschaltet wird. Wenn er Postbote kommt, wird er wieder ausgeschaltet, weil braucht man ja nicht. Das ganze Geschirr, was in der Küche runterfällt, zerklirrt nicht, boing, kommt wieder nach oben und er lebt sozusagen die totale Antithese inmitten dessen.
Genau, das ist toll. Er ist so ein moderner Don Quixote, der ständig mit seiner altmodischen Lebensform gegen die Windmühlen dieser neuen Zeit anrennt. Diese Windmühlen zu ihrer damaligen Zeit waren ja modernste Maschinen. Das ist ja nicht so eine Romantik, die wir denen jetzt zubilligen, sondern damals war das ja was, was jetzt ein Atomkraftwerk ist. Gut, aber noch mal zu...
Aber über längere Laufzeiten der Windmühlen wurde damals nicht verhandelt, oder?
Tja, also es gibt ja wieder neue. Windmühlen 2.0, stehen doch überall, diese Spargeldinger.
Jetzt auch im Ozean.
Aber noch mal zu diesem Gefühl, dass niemand uns gesagt hat, dass wir in einem Erbrochenenbruch leben. Und zwar von dem, der Moderne exemplarisch dargestellt und natürlich ins Groteske übertrieben in diesem Tatifilm und auch vielen anderen Filmen von Jacques Tati. Und auch die Moderne ist für mich in ihrer kristallinen Klarheit mit deinem Eingangssong von Kraftwerk für mich ein Vollstar, Rheinstar, Klarstar, kristalliner Blüte zu erkennen. Der Sound ist ja fast durchsichtig. Das hat eine solche Kraft und Ästhetik. Das ist für mich das Gefühl der Moderne. Dagegen gibt es aber eine Verdunkelung und eine Veränderung, die man schon mit einer Distanzierung begreifen kann. Ich versuche jetzt mal ein paar durch ganz verschiedene gesellschaftliche und kulturelle Phänomene in ein paar Sachen anzuzeigen, die das vielleicht illustrieren können, dass da was passiert ist. Es ist nicht das einzelne Phänomen, sondern es ist mehr die Masse von diesen Beobachtungen, dass da was passiert ist, die dazu führt, dass man sagen kann, da ist ein Epochenbruch passiert. Mir geht es jetzt darum, wann wird dieser Epochenbruch eigentlich in unserer Gesellschaft, insbesondere wir kommen ja aus einem westdeutschen Lager, also wann wurde das eigentlich in Westdeutschland so erkannt? Das ist Anfang der 80er Jahre. Für mich ist 1983 der Beginn der Postmoderne. Also vorher waren wir noch in der Moderne. 1981 kommt die Computerwelt heraus. Da ist also noch das Fortschritts-Dogma noch da. Alles wird schön, die Computer werden uns helfen. Da ist zwar schon eine Ironie drin bei Kraftwerken.
Blühende Landschaften, fliegende Autos, das hat man ja schon mit dem Retro-Futurismus.
Genau. Aber es gibt schon etwas anderes. Und das ist Punk gewesen, der irgendwie sehr regressiv war. Und so, warum zu dieser Zeit? Warum kam so etwas Regressives auf einmal auf? Wir sind so aufgewachsen, dass die Popmusik sich etabliert hat, sogar so als eine ernstzunehmende Kunstform. Man hat versucht quasi, so Classic-Rock zu machen. Also es wurden dann Philharmonie-Orchester mit Rock-Bands gekreuzt. Die Idee war, dass das, was vorher so rebellisch war, in das Herz der ernsten und hohen Kultur einzubringen. Und dann kam Punk und hat das alles kaputt gemacht, weil es einfach nur rumgerotzt hat. Und einen vollkommen nihilistischen No-Future-Anspruch.
Wir spielen nicht mit, egal was ihr euch einfachen lässt.
Und da ist auf einmal in der Popmusik so ein Bruch in diesem Fortschritts-Dogma passiert. Und danach war auch die Musik und auch die Kleidungscodes, die sich damit verbunden haben, auf einmal nicht mehr evanzipatorisch, sondern die Codes, das was die Leute angezogen haben, waren auf einmal Klamotten, die gehörten zu den Formen, die man eigentlich vorher verdammt hatte und in den Orkus werfen wollte. Also Freiheit heißt, ich bin nicht gezwungen, Anzug zu tragen und Krawatte, sondern so wie ich mich fühle. Auf einmal stellen sich aber Leute auf die Bühne, wie bei den New Wave Gruppen, und haben Anzüge an. Und die haben nicht mehr lange Haare, was ja die ganzen 70er Jahre hindurch ein Muster war. Auch vor allen Dingen zu zeigen, ich bin unangepasst, denn ich lasse es einfach der naturfreien Lauf. Ich lasse mich nicht unter die Konformitätszwänge der modernen Welt, nicht nicht der modernen, sondern der Zwangswelt, also die modernen, in dem Sinne war die Emanzipation des Einzelnen. Der soll sich nicht mehr unter Zwänge einordnen müssen, sondern er soll so sein, wie er wirklich ist, und sich frei fühlt. Das war quasi so ein Gefühl einer Weiterführung der Moderne, nämlich, dass man frei ist von Zwängen.
Das heißt, da sind wir jetzt schon bei der Post-Moderne?
Nee, ich versuche noch ein paar Phänomene. Ich bin jetzt gerade bei der Musik und bei der Mode, um zu zeigen, da ist was passiert.
Ist denn die Musik und die Mode da wirklich ein Leitmedium, oder nur ein Ausdruck dessen, was darunter brodelt, deiner Meinung nach?
Für die jungen Leute ist es natürlich ein Leitmedium, gesamtgesellschaftlich gewesen, gesamtgesellschaftlich gesehen, natürlich für diejenigen, die Popmusik nicht als Teil der Jugendkultur empfinden konnten, war das natürlich nur ein Phänomen. Ich geh mal noch weiter. Zum Beispiel die Architektur. Bis Ende der 70er Jahre, ein gutes Beispiel ist zum Beispiel das ICC. Das ICC ist Ende der 70er Jahre in Betrieb genommen worden und ist quasi der Endpunkt der modernen, vom Bauhaus und der rationalen Architektur. Also der vernunftmäßigen Architektur, die ihre Vernunft auch im Design, also im Stil zeigen will. Das ICC ist eine Kongressmaschine und will sich nicht verstellen. Sondern es hockt da wie so ein gewaltiger Flugzeugträger der Konferenzen, auf den Konferenzen einfliegen können und auch wieder rausfliegen können. Alles ist optimiert auf den Austauschprozess.
Vielleicht kurz erwähnen, was wir meinen mit ICC. Das kennt jetzt auch nicht jeder, die Abkürzung. Wir sind ja hier in Berlin und das ICC in Berlin ist sicherlich bekannt, aber trotzdem wollen wir uns mal erklären. International Congress Center heißt es einfach nur. Wir waren jetzt nicht besonders kreativ bei der Namensfindung. Aber du hast recht, die hatte auch schon immer diese Raumschiff-Assoziation. Es gibt vor allem wie ein Raumschiff, was so ein bisschen ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste einfach mal da so gelandet ist und ein buntes Zirkuszelt dabei plattgemacht hat.
Da bist du schon dieses ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste. Da bist du schon bei dem Unbehagen, das sehr viele Leute in ganz verschiedenartiger Form empfunden haben und dem sie sich entgegengestellt haben. Dass diese Moderne ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste nach ganz rigiden Vernunft und Ökonomiezwängen einfach dieses Programm durchführt. Und zwar wirklich ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste. Also was vor 400 Jahren als emanzipatorischer Ansatz angefangen hat, dass man mal Kritik übt und mal an den bestehenden Verhältnissen klopft, hat dazu geführt, dass irgendwann da eine so mächtige Welle und Bewegung entstanden ist, die sehr viele Dinge einfach hinfortgeschwemmt hat und in der letzten Konsequenz auch sich selbst noch mit zersetzt. Also so ein Kannibalisierungseffekt. Aber da kommen wir vielleicht noch gleich. Ich möchte noch ganz kurz auf der Ebene, der für auch denjenigen, der sich philosophisch überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigt hat, sichtbaren Phänomene unserer Umwelt darauf hinweisen, da ist dieser Epochenbruch spürbar. Weil dieses ICC ist nur das Beispiel für das Ende der modernen Architektur, die auch an sich glaubt, dass sie eine Mission hat. Die ist noch leicht angekränkelt, weil wenn du dir die einzelnen Elemente beim ICC anguckst, die sind schon so ein bisschen softer. Die haben so...
Apecken.
Wie heißt das denn? Bevel aus dem 3D-Programm. Ja, die sind so ein bisschen abge... Also ich wollte sagen, naja, wir wissen schon, das ist eine ziemliche Zumutung, aber wir machen es jetzt ein bisschen rund.
Na, sieht aber auch futuristisch aus. Bei Star Trek ist ja auch alles so gebesselt.
Okay, du verteidigst das. Ich sage, das ist schon eine Schwäche. Entweder ich bin...
Okay, ich hab nicht gesagt, das ist verteidigt. Ich hab nur gesagt, bei Star Trek ist es genauso. Vielleicht haben die auch von Anfang an geschwächelt.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass sich die Moderne an diesem Punkt schon nicht mehr so ganz sicher ist, dass sie das richtige Programm produziert.
Du weißt, sie waren nicht mehr so bereit, so brutal zu sein, jetzt wie bei den ganzen Hochhausbauten.
Genau, genau.
Einfach so viereckig reicht vollkommen aus. Maximal Raumnutzung liebt es jetzt.
Also da kommt schon so eine Softigkeit mit rein. Aber was ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Endpunkt? Und was kommt danach? Da kommt die postmoderne und vielleicht postmodane Architektur. Das war auf einmal etwas vollkommen Ungesehenes. Auf Neubauten waren kleine Zwiebeltürmchen und vollkommen zweckfreie, so römische Portale. Gibt es auch im Zuge der internationalen Bauausstellung, 1987 gibt es, das war ja so eine Art Showcase, das heißt ganz viele berühmte Architekten wurden eingeladen, Wohnhäuser zu bauen, in Westberlin.
87.
87 war das. Übrigens 30 Jahre nach der ersten internationalen Bauausstellung, die das Hansa-Viertel gebaut hat. Dort wurden alle internationalen modernen Architekten eingeladen und die haben quasi den damaligen State of the Art der Moderne in ihrer wirklich vollkommen unangekränkelten Form dadurch gesetzt, auch mit einer gewissen nach wie vor spürbaren Qualität. Das hat sich nun dann pervertiert in Gropius-Stadt und Märkischen-Viertel, ist davon dann nichts mehr zu sehen. Dass das Programm auch nicht nur einfach ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste sein kann, sondern dass es eben auch auf seine Umgebung einwirkt. Und dann auf einmal kommt jetzt ein Bauen, wo so eine neue Gemütlichkeit, so ein Historismus, Zwiebeltürmchen, in der Wilhelmstraße stehen so ein paar von diesen Teilen. Wer da mal vorbeigefahren ist, der... Ja, auf einmal kommen ornamentale Elemente ins Spiel, die es 20, 30 Jahre lang einfach nicht geben durfte. Also du warst quasi als Architekt, hättest du dich vor deinen Standesgenossen absolut der Lächerlichkeit preisgegeben.
Wenn man noch irgendein Verspiel, das er eingebracht hätte.
Ornament als Verbrechen ist so ein Titel einer Kampfschrift, die, ich weiß nicht aus welcher Zeit, jedenfalls quasi gesagt hat, die Architektur muss sich auf die Funktion beschränken und darf hier nicht so Zuckerbäckerstil betreiben. In der Zeit haben auch die ganzen westlichen Architekten auf die Architekten der Stalinallee in Ostberlin einfach nur mit vollkommenem Spott und Hohn auf diesen Zuckerbäckerstil geschaut. Und jetzt auf einmal 30 Jahre später taucht so eine Art Zuckerbäckerstil überall auf. Und alle finden das toll. Übrigens auch mit Design. Es kommt das Memphis-Design. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das noch im Auge hast. Das waren auf einmal Regale, die sahen aus wie Bauglötschen in ganz vielen bunten Primärfarben zusammengesetzt. Es kamen Kaffeetannen, wo die hatten auf einmal so einen blauen Pinöpel auf dem Deckel und irgendwie... Ich weiß nicht, wer auf dem Deckel ist.
Was ist denn mit 100 Wasser? Der ist doch von der Architektur...
Das ist Kitsch, den müssen wir weglassen.
Du meinst, das ist schon Beyond Ornament? Was ist mit Gaudi? Der war doch früh dran und der war doch auch sehr...
Ich will noch dran erinnern. Du bringst mich nicht durcheinander, du stellst die richtigen Fragen. Ich muss nur die Chance haben, sie dann auch noch beantworten zu können. Die Idee, erst wenn im Querschnitt der verschiedenen kulturellen Disziplinen zur selben Zeit oder zur annähernd selben Zeit überall dieselbe Bewegung, derselbe Bruch zu spüren ist, dann kann man vom Epochenbruch sprechen. Dann sind nämlich auch die gesellschaftlichen Filter durchgängig so gepolt, dass sie diese Phänomene durchlassen. Das heißt, es gibt immer, zu jeder Zeit in einer Gesellschaft Dinge, die passieren. Es kommt nur darauf an, in welcher Form sie überhaupt als handwerklich korrekte Formen dieser Disziplinen wahrgenommen werden. Also Hundertwasser hat zu einer Zeit seine amorphen Gebäude gebaut, wo alle nur Rechtecke gesetzt haben. Der war quissermaßen ein Außenseiter und als solcher wurde der auch gar nicht ernst genommen. Erst 30 Jahre später waren gewissermaßen die Filter so gesetzt, dass alle gesagt haben, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Und auf einmal wurde jemand, der gegen die Regeln gearbeitet hat, als eine neue Möglichkeitenform innerhalb dieser Disziplinen, sei es das Bauen, sei es das Musizieren, wahrgenommen zu werden.
So steigt man dann auf zum Visionär?
Ja, so wird man... Postum? Ja, aber man wird vor allen Dingen überhaupt erst mal anerkannt, dass man sich überhaupt rechtmäßig in dieser Disziplin, sei es Musik, Architektur, bewegt. Vorher ist man einfach nur ein Dilettant. Oder man ist naiv, oder man macht Kitsch. Und ist gewissermaßen aus dem Feld ausgeschlossen. So, jetzt haben wir drei Beispiele.
Wir bewegen uns. Ich muss jetzt auch mal ein bisschen kontextualisieren. Wir sind ja im Prinzip immer noch dabei, die Moderne einzumauern und zu gucken, wo sie irgendwie angefangen hat und aufgehört hat. Und wenn ich mich richtig verstehe, auch so ein bisschen, wo sie sich selbst überlebt hat. Wo sie so selbst ein bisschen gegen die Wand gelaufen ist, weil einfach die Akzeptanz für das Moderne nicht mehr da war. Weil es an zunehmendem Maße auch als Bedrohung wahrgenommen wird. Als Bedrohung, dadurch, dass es ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste, auf bestehendes Traditionelles draufklatscht. Weil es aber auch einfach nichts Schönes mehr fürs Auge bietet. Und so ein Konformismus einen aufzwingt, wirklich mit dem Minimum zu leben. Kann man das so durchgehen lassen, diese Analyse?
Das kann man durchgehen lassen. Nur worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist, dass ich sagen möchte, es gibt offensichtlich so etwas wie einen Bruch zwischen einem klassischen, modernen Paradigma. Jetzt bring ich mal so einen Begriff hinein, der sehr oft benutzt wird. Also ein Feld von äquivalenten Begriffen, die wie in einer Schublade liegen und die man entsprechend benutzen kann, um ähnliche Dinge zu bezeichnen. Und dieses Paradigma von Stilmitteln ist auf einmal ein anderes in der Postmoderne als in der klassischen Moderne. Und weil das jetzt so eine Behauptung ist, versuche ich ein paar hoffentlich allen bekannten Erscheinungsformen, wie es gibt New Wave und nicht mehr Bombastrock aller Genesis. Und dann kommt auf einmal so ganz sparsames New Wave-nervöses Musizieren heraus.
Was meinst du, so was wie The Cure?
Ja, oder Television, oder Ideal. Und man singt auf einmal auf Deutsch, und das ist sogar cool. Und vor allen Dingen, ich will denen zeigen, es kommt mir auf den Bruch an, weil die Stilmittel sind vollkommen unterschiedlich. Bei der Musik ist es nämlich genau umgekehrt vom Ornament, also Bombast Rock, total aufgeblasener Scheiß, zum vollkommen runter reduzierten Musizieren einer New Wave Band wie Joy Division zum Beispiel.
Inwiefern beschreibst du das Ganze global? Oder haben wir hier eine europäische Perspektive gerade?
Ja, wir haben die im weitesten Sinne der westlichen Welt, wo immer die beginnt und wo auch immer die endet. Ist denn für dich diese drei Beispiele eines Epochenbruchs nachvollziehbar? Und zwar nicht eines, dass überall die gleichen Stilmittel angewandt sind, sondern dass man einfach nur erst mal feststellen kann, da ist was passiert, was nicht mehr in einer Kontinuität, sondern in einer Diskontinuität.
Auf welche drei brichst du es jetzt zusammen?
Von der klassischen Rockmusik zum New Wave, vom klassischen International Style der Architektur zur postmodernen Zuckerbäckerarchitektur, bei der Mode oder bei den Jugendmoden auf einmal nicht mehr die Mode des sich betont lockergebens, sondern eine Mode des auch ironischen Spiels mit formalisierten Kleidungsformen, also man trägt wieder Anzug, man nimmt auch Bezug auf schon vergangene Formen von Mode, also diese Idee der Retro- und Revival-Geschichten sind gewissermaßen aus einer Erschöpfung der Moderne entstanden, dass es keine sinnvolle Weiterführung mehr gibt, sondern man scheint an den Endpunkt gekommen zu sein und interessant sind auf einmal vergangene Formen.
Du meinst, Retro ist wirklich ein Phänomen, was dann erst nach der Moderne aufgeschrieben wird? Du sagst nicht, dass man grundsätzlich immer Retro hat?
Nein.
Das muss nicht so bleiben?
Doch, es gibt immer Retro, aber das bleibt dann, was heute vielleicht so Western-Nostalgiker sind, die irgendwo sich ihre, ja, die gibt es immer.
Cowboy und Indianer spielen?
Genau, aber wenn die auf einmal massenhaft auftreten und nicht so komische Spinner sind, sondern auf einmal coole Slacker sind, die überall im Szene-Café auftauchen, dann ist da was passiert.
Naja, also so Versammlungen mit Leuten mit Cowboy-Hüten habe ich in Berlin ja auch schon ein paar erlebt. Das Gefühl hier wird wirklich jeder Moderne oder auch der Postmoderne manchmal noch ein Schnippchen geschlagen, was die Mode und den Ausdruck betrifft.
Das muss sich die Postmoderne auch gefallen lassen. Ich versuche jetzt noch zwei andere, also das waren die drei Beispiel, die ich genannt habe. Mode, Popmusik, Architektur. Ich möchte jetzt noch Film und Fernsehen dazu bringen. Was fällt mir da ein? Eine Fernsehserie, da muss man noch wirklich sagen können, irgendwas ist doch an dieser Fernsehserie anders, als man das bisher bei Fernsehserien gekannt hat.
Alles war anders, meiner Meinung nach. Alles war anders, ich war anders danach.
Genau.
Twin Peaks hat mich echt überfahnt. Hab ich zwar eine Weile für gebraucht, aber das lag an der schlechten Verfügbarkeit der Serie lange Zeit.
Und damit bist du in den Zustand überführt worden, in einen postmodernen Zustand.
Twin Peaks hat mich in einen postmodernen Zustand überführt. Das ist gut.
Oder sagen wir das postmoderne Empfinden hat sich dir eingeschrieben.
Ich hatte auch mit Brasil schon so einen ähnlichen Voreffekt. Der war nicht ganz so verwirrend, aber...
So, und jetzt komme ich als damals jugendlicher Mensch, habe quasi für mich einen diesen Umschlag von sich in der Moderne, dem Fortschritt zur Sonne, zur Freiheit, in irgendeiner Form nähernd wahrgenommen, zu einem neuen Form des kulturellen, einer der kulturellen Welt, das irgendwie geht es jetzt anders weiter, als man es sich in der Fortschreibung der bisherigen erlernten Kontinuität sich vorgestellt hätte, ist jetzt was anders geworden. Und das war für mich 1983, vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen vorher, in der Musik kam auf New Wave, Neue Deutsche Welle, das war wie so eine Explosion. Alle hatten auf einmal so komische deutsche Namen, die immer so abstürzende Brieftauben bis einstürzende Neubauten und so. Da ist quasi ein ganz neues Paradigma aufgetaucht, wie jetzt das zu klingen hat, wenn junge Menschen Musik machen und dazu Spaß haben wollen und in welcher Sprache sie sich bedienen und in welcher Metaphorik sie sich bedienen. Das war für mich ein ganz klarer Bruch. Dann kam eben auch in der Mode ein Bruch. Die Jeans waren mal für eine Zeit lang suspendiert. Keiner hat Jeans getragen, sondern alle so komische Chino's und so eine Popper-Kleidung. Das war zumindest da, wo ich gelebt habe, das war das sehr, sehr stark.
Und die Frisuren nicht zu vergessen, diese Popperschäden, das war wirklich ganz furchtbar.
Ja, die so ein bisschen in das Schwiegermamas Lieblings Frisur hineinkamen. Und dann zu der Zeit habe ich mich auch stärker mit Architektur auseinandergesetzt und habe dann auch so etwas erfahren, aha, da gibt es offensichtlich eine Krise des modernen Bauens. Und mit der Rückführung, also quasi so einem Retro-Aspekt in der Architektur, man nimmt ästhetisch zufriedenstellende Formen aus dem klassischen Altertum oder aus der Renaissance und nutzt die als Zitate, um einfach das Bauen wieder schöner zu machen. Und das ist so für mich quasi der Beginn der Postmoderne gewesen, wo ich mich quasi postmodern gefühlt habe. Also nicht erst 1988 mit Twin Peaks, sondern ein paar Jahre vorher.
Und ich erst mit Twin Peaks, ein paar Jahre nachdem Twin Peaks ausgestrahlt wurde.
Genau, ich würde dir dort eine gewisse historische Verspätung... Verschleppung, ich hab's nur verschleppt.
Ich war mit dem Internet beschäftigt, das war auch sehr... Na ja, was denn jetzt eigentlich? Ist das Internet eigentlich modern oder postmodern?
Das sollten wir zum Schluss nochmal erklären oder diskutieren. Und jetzt kommt für mich der Ausgangspunkt, warum ich vorgeschlagen hab, diesen Podcast zu machen. Wir sind jetzt schon halb durch.
Sind wir nicht, nein, nein, wir reden eine halbe Stunde.
Umso länger die Einführung ist, desto eher bin ich nicht gezwungen, auf die wirklich schlimmen Dinge zu sprechen zu kommen.
Na ja, es wird spannend. Ich finde, wir haben einen Spannungsbogen aufgebaut.
Weil 1983, Anfang der 80er Jahre, gibt es auch in der Bundesrepublik einen politischen Umbruch von den 13 Jahren der sozialliberalen Koalition, die klassisch das Programm der moderne Emanzipation des Einzelnen gegen bestimmte gesellschaftlich- konservative Interessen versucht haben, durchzusetzen und mehr Bildung für die Arbeiterkinder. Riesige Universitäten, natürlich auch so Monster-Maschinen-Universitäten wurden gebaut. Aber es war ja alles im Sinne des Guten, aber richtig gut. Die Autobahnen wurden alle erweitert. Mehr Spuren, mehr Lebensfreude. Überall wurden Schwimmbäder. Es war eine riesige Infrastrukturwelle getragen. Von dem Bewusstsein, dass man den bisher entrechteten und zu kurz gekommenen einfach einen Platz an der Sonne bieten kann. Dann kam diese Zeit mit der CDU, FDP-geführten Regierung. Und komischerweise passte das zusammen. Dieses politische Emanzipationsschema war zu der Zeit für mich kulturell parallel laufend mit der kulturellen Weg nach vorne in den Fortschritt. Und auf einmal kommt so ein Bruch. Es kommt eine konservative Regierung, die machen komische Sachen, erzählen Dinge, die sind so ein bisschen anders. Geistig-moralische Wände, klingt so ein bisschen altfränkisch. Also es wirkt auch ein bisschen angestaubt, aber komischerweise reagieren Dinge in der Kultur darauf. Denn auf einmal kommen Parallelfenomene dazu. Das heißt, diesen Bruch, moderne, postmoderne, mache ich in Deutschland jetzt sogar an einem Regierungswechsel fest, was ziemlich particular ist. Weil in Frankreich war es genau umgekehrt. Zu der Zeit sind die Sozialisten mit Mitterrand die Macht gekommen. Es ist wirklich ein regionales Phänomen der Bundesrepublik. Deswegen war es für mich leichter, quasi an diesem Ende 82, 83, so einen Globalklimawandel, der sich da gesellschaftlich für mich stattgefunden hat, wahrzunehmen. Und jetzt noch mal zur Perente. Jetzt habe ich gemerkt, dass die wirklich entscheidenden theoretischen Grundlagen für das, was dann Postmoderne genannt wird, in Frankreich im Jahre 1968 aufgetreten sind. Und jetzt kommt für mich auf einmal ein spannender Aspekt hinein, weil für mich war 68 ein Wiederanknüpfen an eine ganz traditionelle, moderne, aufklärerische Bewegung. Also der SDS, der sozialistisch-deutsche Studentenwund, die haben in der Nachfolge der marxistischen Theorie versucht, die Dinge zu verändern. Sie haben das Gefühl gehabt aus der marxistischen Lehre heraus, dass sie dazu ein Recht hätten. Und das war ja auch die Auffassung der gesamten Linke, dass sie da ein weltgeschichtliches Programm zu erfüllen hätten. Mit quasi wissenschaftlichen Anspruch, der philosophisch begründet worden ist im 19. Jahrhundert.
Wissenschaftlicher Anspruch?
Ja, das ist das Tolle. Die Marxisten sind deswegen so unglaublich zäh Gesellen gewesen. Und nach wie vor.
Weil sie alles mathematisch herleiten können?
Weil sie der Überzeugung sind, dass sie eine Art Weltformel gefunden haben, nach der sie von Anbeginn menschlicher Existenz nicht nur bis in die Gegenwart, sondern auch in die Projektion der Zukunft hinaus genau wissen, wie die Geschichte abzulaufen hat. Alle Phänomene, die dabei unterwegs auftreten, sind im Zweifelsfalle Nebenwidersprüche, so wie so ein Fluss, wenn da ein Stein im Weg liegt, das dann mal so ein Wirbel bildet, wo sich auch mal so Treibsand und so. Das sind Nebenwidersprüche. Jeder Fluss führt zum Meer. Und wenn du, lieber Freund, da einen Staudamm aufbaust, dann bist du Reaktion. Dann stellst du dich letztlich gegen den Lauf der Zeit. Genau, gegen den Lauf der Geschichte.
Und du willst das Unverhinderbare sozusagen aufhalten.
Vor allen Dingen, du bist auch so, also jetzt von der marxistischen Sicht heraus, bist du heute das, wenn du das leugnest, wenn du gegen die Auffassung vom Menschen gemachten Klimawandel wärst. Also so wie der IPCC, der Weltklimarat jetzt festgestellt hat, der Mensch beeinflusst das Weltklima, so ist für einen richtigen Marxisten die marxistische Theorie genauso wissenschaftlich belegt.
Immer noch.
Also, naja, die meisten sind glaube ich inzwischen nicht mehr ganz so überzeugt.
Die schwächeln.
Nach 89 sind viele zusammengebrochen, wirklich mental.
Gut, aber 68 waren sie alle noch ganz fit drauf.
Insbesondere in, genau, diese marxistische, durch diese lange Epoche des Faschismus, des Weltkriegs, gab es einen gewissen Aufstau. Und jeder hat auch gesehen, so wie sich der Marxismus in Russland und in der Sowjetunion entwickelt hat, ist der natürlich nicht das, was man als die geeignete Antwort auf diese marxistisch-wissenschaftlich vermeintlich belegbaren Grundlagen haben will. Aber die theoretische Begründung wurde nach wie vor als legitim angesehen und auf Basis einer neuen, sogenannten kritischen Theorie des Marxismus wurde quasi eine gewisse Kontinuität festgestellt, dass das grundsätzlich seine Richtigkeit hat mit dem, was Marx und seine Nachfolger gesagt haben und dass man infolgedessen auf Basis dieser vereinheitlichen Theorie auch tätig werden muss. Man muss sogar tätig werden, weil man sich sonst gegen Naturgesetzlichkeiten, gegen wissenschaftlich nachweisbare Evidenzen stellen würde, was einen gewissermaßen zu einem nicht mehr ernst zu nehmenden Zeitgenossen macht. Also dadurch kam auch eine gewisse Überheblichkeit gegenüber denjenigen, die das so nicht geteilt haben.
Waren sich denn jetzt diese 68, da war ja noch die Moderne eigentlich noch voll am Rocken.
Ja, und da ist das Interessante. Und in Frankreich, in Paris eben nicht. Da kam schon der erste kleine Säureanschlag durch ein Denken, dass dieses mit sich noch vollkommen im Reinen befindliche Fortschrittsdogma der Moderne repräsentiert im Marxismus durchbrochen hat. Jetzt wollen wir einfach mal, wir haben jetzt quasi ein bisschen über das Ende der Moderne gesprochen, aber ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nochmal den Begriff was ist denn eigentlich die Moderne ganz kurz einführen, weil wenn wir jetzt über die Postmoderne sprechen, über postmodernes Denken, finde ich es blöd, wenn wir nicht jetzt wenigstens sagen würden, wovon setzt sich das denn ab? Haben wir beide denn überhaupt einen einheitlichen Begriff von dem, was die Moderne oder wie Sozialdemokraten sagen würden, von dem Projekt der Moderne?
Vor allem, bis wir dann noch auf das eigentliche Thema der Sendung zu sprechen kommen, den Strukturalismus und die Poststrukturen.
Nee, ich finde wir sind schon...
Ja du findest das, aber haben wir das schon gesagt?
Da innerhalb... Das Sein kann sich seines Seins nur dadurch vergewertigen, dass es sich in seinem Wesen sieht. Das Wesen ist natürlich nur das, was schon gewesen ist. Das heißt, eben auf der Vollendung des Wesens kommt das Sein zum Vorschein. Das hat glaube ich Heidegger gesagt. Und so müssen wir auch die Bewegungen dieser Sendung sehen. Das heißt, indem wir das ganze Feld aufrollen, kommen wir am Ende vielleicht zu einer Einsicht dessen, dass wir wissen, worüber wir sprechen wollten.
Ja, das ist super. Ich find den Ansatz ganz toll. Aber ja, dann möchtest du also jetzt... Also wir haben quasi beleuchtet...
Du könntest ja mal... Die Frage jetzt geht mal an dich. Was ist denn die Moderne?
Was ist die Moderne?
Ja.
Nach dem, was du mir jetzt erklärt hast.
Ich hab's dir noch gar nicht erklärt. Ich bin nur der Meinung, ich müsste es jetzt...
Du hast nur das Ende der Moderne erklärt.
Ja, und zwar auch nur so anhand ihrer Äußerlichkeiten. Aber die Moderne jetzt nicht nur als einen Stil, den man in der Mode oder sonst was nennt, sondern die Moderne als eine Epoche. Abgesetzt von...
Gut, ich kann ja nur meine leihenhafte Interpretation einbringen. Für mich klingt bei Moderne die Gesellschaft an, die vor allem geprägt war durch ein paar ganz entscheidende Erfindungen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt Zivilisation sagen kann, aber...
Zivilisation sicherlich nicht, weil da würde man sagen, mittelalterlich gesellschaftliche Gesellschaften, das römische Imperium, das waren alles Non-Zivilisationen.
Definitiv waren das auch schon Zivilisationen. Das hier, das wir raus, hat auf jeden Fall was mit Strom zu tun. Also ohne Strom, keine Moderne. Ich würde der Moderne auch eine gewisse globale Awareness schon unterstellen wollen. Das ist nichts, was einfach nur an einem einzigen Fleck dieses Planeten hat entstehen können. Das hat sicherlich nicht alles abgedeckt, aber gerade der Kontext der westlichen Welt und ihre ausufernde Entwicklung und infrastrukturelle Entwicklung, Entwicklung der Kommunikation, das Telefon, spielt eine große Rolle, die Medien. Da würde ich die Moderne ansiedeln, wo das jetzt nur konkret seinen Beginn genommen hat. Keine Ahnung.
Schön finde ich bei dem, was du jetzt gesagt hast, dass du die Prozesshaftigkeit, die Dynamik betonst, dass wer auch immer über Moderne spricht, sieht gewissermaßen eine Art Momentum des Wandels. Und zwar dieses Momentum wird aber inzwischen quasi schon als etwas Statisches gesehen. Also es muss sich ständig was ändern, sonst haben wir ein Problem. Das ist eine Befindlichkeit, die z.B. die frühen, also die vormoderne Gesellschaft nicht hatten.
Da hat niemand von Wachstum geredet.
Also zwischen der Technik im alten Rom und im 14. Jahrhundert, die ist wie heute und vor 20 Jahren. Du hättest sofort einen römischen Feldherrn tausend Jahre in die Zukunft versetzen können. Der hätte sich kurz orientiert und dann hätte er gewusst, was läuft, hätte sich gewundert vielleicht über den einen. Was sind denn das für Langbogenschützen, die uns hier abknallen? Die haben aber eine Schussweite. Das kenne ich nicht von den Barbaren. Da hätte er gesagt, Holla, und was sind diese Explosivkugeln, die mich hier umpfeifen? Dann hätte er, das sind wie so kleine Vulkanen.
Schusswaffen, hätte ich jetzt schon gesagt, das ist schon eine der schwerwiegenderen Einschnitte.
Ja, aber ich glaube auch, ein guter römischer Feldherr hätte damit noch... Also ich will damit nur kurz sagen, dass lange Zeit über sowas wie Dynamik und Veränderung überhaupt nicht stattgefunden hat und deswegen auch nicht problematisiert werden musste oder thematisiert worden oder idealisiert werden müsste im Sinne von, das finden wir auch gut so, dass sich so viel wandelt. Aber ich will noch...
Die Kommunikation war nicht deutlich verändert in der einen Zeit zur anderen Zeit. Also musste immer noch der Reiter durch die Gegend gejagt werden.
Wir haben natürlich in der Medientechnologie mit dem Buchdruck sicherlich einen ganz, ganz wichtigen Ansatzpunkt, der dazu führt zur Dynamik der Moderne. Weil einfach dieser Flaschenhals, dass da Mönche immer dasselbe Pergament abmalen, das ist auf einmal durch die Mechanisierung des Druckverfahrens anders geworden.
An dieser Stelle muss ich natürlich auch nochmal auf den Chaosradio Express Geschichte der Typografie hinweisen, wo diese ganze Geschichte von Gutenberg bis zur modernen Setzmaschine ausführlich besprochen wurde. Aber auch diese Aspekte der Auswirkungen dieser Entwicklung.
Aber ich möchte Moderne jetzt nicht nur verstehen als Geschichte der Emanzipation und des Wandels und des Fortschritts in Anführungsstrichen durch technologische Erfindung. Das ist nur ein Aspekt. Der wichtige der Moderne als ein geistiges Programm liegt in dem, was man Aufklärung genannt hat. Aufklärung, glaube ich, in der kürzesten Formel ist die Emanzipation des Menschen durch die von ihm selbst geschaffenen Wiedrigkeiten. Ist jetzt nicht so toll, ich glaube, es gibt noch...
Wiedrigkeiten?
Ja.
Ich emanzipiere mich, indem ich mir selbst Wiedrigkeiten zufüge?
Nein.
Was ist das so?
Nein, nein.
Kauft sich ein Windows-Rechner und kommt dann so zum neuen...
Ist das eine neue Bewusstseinsstufe?
Nein, es geht um fundamentalere Sachen. Um Herrschaft, um Legitimation. Dass es Klassen gibt, dass es... Du bist als Bauer geboren und hast als Bauer zu sterben. Dass es einen Adel gibt, der als Adel geboren ist. Das sind doch alles nur Menschen, die barrieren dazwischen. Wer hat die denn verfügt? Also die Aufklärung des Menschen vor den von ihm selbst in seiner Gesellschaft eingefügten Restrains. Das finde ich jetzt mal als englisches Wort schön.
Eine Bewusstwerdung der realen Situation würde ich mal sagen.
Genau. Und an der Stelle war natürlich immer die gottgewollte Ordnung ein wichtiger Punkt, die gewissermaßen als außerhalb der menschlichen Gesellschaft diese Restrains verfügende Macht.
Die einfach da war.
Die war gesetzt. Die war gesetzt und hat ja auch eine tolle Logik, weil sie nämlich die sinnproduzierende Einheit für alles ist. Dass es eine Welt gibt, dass es Menschen gibt, dass es eine Natur gibt, dass wir wissen, all das liegt darin, dass es einen Gott gibt, der zu seinem Wohlgefallen und in seinem Ebenbild uns in die Welt gesetzt hat, um vielleicht sogar sich selber in uns wiederzuerkennen. Und je gottgefälliger wir ihn widerspiegeln, desto eher werden wir in unserer Elendigkeit im späteren Leben in ihm aufgehen und all diese Bürden werden anständig entlohnt.
Praktischerweise hat uns dann auch noch ein paar Stellvertreter hingegeben, denen wir sozusagen auch noch die Kohle zuschieben können.
Aber an dem Punkt, meine ich, trifft der Vorwurf, dass die islamische Welt noch in diesem vormodernen Status ist. Die übernimmt zwar die modernen Techniken, aber benutzt die gewissermaßen für eine geistige Formation, die wir als vormodern sehen würden.
So eine Moderne hat es da nicht gegeben, meinst du?
Oder eine Aufklärung über die Grundlagen des eigenen Wissens. In dem Sinne, dass nämlich, jetzt müssen wir mal ganz kurz auf die Philosophie kommen, die hat nämlich dann überlegt, wer einfach aus einer grundsätzlichen Neugierde heraus über den Menschen, wie er so die Welt sieht und dass er so denken kann und schreibt, dass er entsprechend natürlich versuchen musste, wer ist denn das eigentlich, der da denkt und urteilt und daraus eine Bewusstseinsphilosophie entstanden ist, die quasi diese Fesseln an den Gott als das letztbestimmende Prinzip gekappt hat. Als Beispiel, also diese Bewegung wurde durch die kathesianische Wende, also Dekat, hat durch dieses Kogito ergo sum, eine neue Möglichkeit, eine Existenzbegründung ohne Gott eingeführt. Er hat die, insofern eingeführt, ich will das mal...
Durch diesen Satz.
Durch diesen Satz, weil...
Ich denke, also bin ich.
Genau, weil dieses, ich denke, also bin ich, ist die letzte uns innerweltlich mögliche Instanz, die wir bestimmen können, die alle anderen weltlichen Erkenntnisse strukturiert. Das heißt, für all das, was in der Welt passiert, brauchst du keinen Gott, sondern du brauchst nur deinen Verstand. Und das führt quasi zu einem Ausschluss von Gott aus der richtigen Welt. Gott ist, wenn überhaupt, nur noch eine Art Anlasser, der irgendwann mal diesen Weltmotor gestartet hat, aber der jetzt, wie so was, autonom aus sich heraus, also dieser Funke, der jedes Mal eine Explosion ausführt, das ist jetzt der Mensch, der ist dieser göttliche Funke, der muss nicht mit jedem Arbeitstakt von Gott kommen, sondern der hat das zwar am Anfang aller Zeiten das einmal eingeführt, ist an die Initialzündung gegeben, aber seitdem sind wir mit unserem Verstand diese Funken, die die Welt, und zwar Welt ist ja nur dann Welt, wenn sie sinnvoll strukturiert werden kann, wenn sie erkannt werden kann. Das heißt, ohne ein Erkennendes ist die Welt vollkommen unerheblich.
Sprich Gott müsste erst dann wieder angerufen werden, wenn alle aufgehört haben zu denken.
Genau.
Dieser Eindruck stellt sich manchmal aber schon ein.
Ja, auf der Alltagsebene durchaus.
Oder wenn man Fernsehen guckt, ganz schlimm. Aber davon ist man ja mittlerweile auch abgekommen, oder? Ich meine, dieser göttliche Funke geht ja mittlerweile auch unter in so einer neuen Glauben an die Wissenschaft.
Gut, jetzt kommen wir dem Phänomen, was ist die Moderne, schon ganz gut nahe. Weil wir haben jetzt eine Selbstermächtigung des Menschen gegenüber Gott. Gott ist jetzt aus der Welt verdrängt. Und mit der Dynamik ist Gott auch quasi in so eine Vorzeitigkeit entrückt. Also Gott wurde noch nicht als Prinzip beerdigt, aber er ist jedenfalls nicht mehr anwesend. Sondern wir sind auch durch unsere Vernunft die Stellvertreter Gottes. Und das ist auch recht logisch, weil man auf einmal deuten konnte, naja, Gott schuf den Menschen nach seinem Ebenbild. War natürlich dann auf einmal sehr schön, weil man ihn auch jetzt nicht mehr so denken musste, Gott muss aussehen wie ein Mensch. Sondern diese Ebenbildhaftigkeit ist, dass Gott die allumfassende Vernunft ist. Und wir sind gewissermaßen mit unserer Vernunft das Ebenbild Gottes. Und was ja dazu führt, dass auch die christliche Auslegung von der Bibel sich emanzipieren konnte und sagt, das sind alles nur Sprachbilder für die damaligen geschichtlichen Auffassungen. Wir nehmen jetzt einfach den Sinngehalt dessen, was da gesagt wird, und übertragen das in unsere sich dynamisierende Welt. Wir brauchen den Gott nicht mehr als Väterchen mit einem langen Bart, der da oben auf der Wolke sitzt, sondern wir machen eine Abstraktion von Gott. Denn er hat uns die Fähigkeit gegeben zu abstrahieren, nämlich, dass wir nur noch mit der Vernunft als dem letzten wirklich fassbaren Grunde unserer Erkenntnis operieren können und setzen ihn in Bezug zu dieser Vernunft. Und sagen, wir sind da quasi Teilvernünfte oder innerweltliche Teilvernünfte. Es gibt auch sowas wie die absolute Vernunft.
Wir sind Gott.
Wir sind dadurch Gott. Wir sind Papst. Wir sind mehr als Papst. Wir führen die Letzbegründung in uns ein.
Was für eine Begründung?
Die Letzbegründung.
Die Letzbegründung. Ja.
Das ist ganz wichtig. Das ist noch viel wichtiger als Engführung. Letzbegründung ist die Frage nach dem Universum.
Leben dem Universum und dem ganzen Rest. Die Antwort kennen wir ja schon.
In der Philosophie wird diese Frage nach der Letzbegründung Metaphysik genannt, weil sie eben über die innerweltlich erfassbaren Erkenntnisse hinausgeht. Aber wenn es etwas gibt, weil es gibt natürlich in der Sinne des folgerichtigen Denkens, kannst du ja keine Wirkung ohne Ursache dir vorstellen. Die Philosophie hat verschiedene Fragestellungen. In der Logik ist das Trainingsprogramm der Vernunft. Damit wird die Vernunft sich ihre eigenen Möglichkeiten klar.
Was ist das Trainingsprogramm?
Die Logik.
Die Logik ist das Trainingsprogramm der Vernunft.
Daran schult sie und trainiert sie ihre eigene Urteilsfähigkeit. Erst wenn sie innerhalb dieser formalen Aussagen bestimmte Aktionen und Prämissen und Gesetzmäßigkeiten folgerichtig schließen kann, kann sie glissermaßen mit dieser Autorität auch Schlüsse außerhalb eines formalen Bereichs, der Logik oder der Mathematik, auf einmal auch formale Schlüsse und Erkenntnisse auf die Welt hinaus projizieren.
Heißt das, dass wenn ich logisch denken kann, auch nicht in der Lage ist vernünftig zu handeln?
Natürlich. Das wurde einiges erklärt. Wir bewegen uns natürlich immer in Idealtypen. Das heißt, diese Vernunft ist eine virtuelle Möglichkeit, von der wir sagen, dass sie jedem Menschen eingegeben sei. Dass sie aber natürlich nicht in allen Menschen zur vollen Entfaltung kommt, ist ein anderes Problem. Unter Umständen auch eines, das der Marxismus vielleicht lösen wollte. Ich will nur noch mal ganz schön erklären für diejenigen, die sagen, Philosophie ist so ein Scheiß. Philosophie hat halt ein paar zentrale Fragestellungen seit etwa zweieinhalbtausend Jahren. Und die haben sich durchgängig bewährt, im Sinne, dass man sogar noch mit Philosophen von vor 2000 Jahren sich auseinandersetzen kann, wie wir beide jetzt ein Gespräch führen. Weil diese Fragestellungen einfach so fundamental sind, dass sie damals gestellt worden sind von Leuten, die sich ihrer Vernunft, ihres Verstandes bedient haben. Und man heute erst mal zu keiner anderen Frage kommt und die Antworten auch nicht unbedingt überzeugender sind. Das heißt, es gibt in der Philosophie zumindest bis zur Postmoderne, jetzt wird es ziemlich interessant, eine gewisse Überzeitlichkeit, eine Nichtgeschichtlichkeit des Wissens.
So eine generelle Anwendbarkeit der philosophischen Grundsätze.
Genau, genau. Kant hat gesagt, die wichtigen Fragen sind, was kann ich wissen, was darf ich tun, was darf ich hoffen und was zum Teufel bin überhaupt ich?
Das hat er gesagt?
Das hat er gesagt.
Während Descarta irgendwie mit, ich denke also bin ich, ich bin halt einfach.
Na der hat wesentliche Grundlagen gelegt, dass er quasi den Menschen mal zu einem bisher nicht bekannten Problem auch der Erkenntnis geführt hat. Weil solange es einen obersten Gott gibt, der alle möglichen Phänomene der Welt, Tiere, Pflanzen, Menschen, Gebäude, Meere eingesetzt hat, ist der Mensch ja nur ein Phänomen in einer Ebene.
Er ist einfach Deko.
Er tut wie alle anderen Dinge tun, was in diesem Programm vorgesehen ist. Indem aber der Mensch sich zu der, zumindest innerweltlich, nicht mehr der physisch einzigen Instanz aufschwingt, die Fragen stellen kann und sich damit ein Verhältnis zu allen anderen Phänomenen in der wahrnehmbaren Welt aufschwingt, wird die Frage, wer ist der Mensch, zu einer ganz zentralen Fragestellung. Und die Philosophen haben dann mit dieser zentralen Fragestellung natürlich arbeiten müssen und haben in verschiedenen Bereichen versucht, die Probleme zu lösen. Weil, was sind überhaupt Erkenntnisse? Das war für die ein wichtiges Problem, bevor sie quasi sagen konnten, da hinten sitzt eine Instanz, die verarbeitet all diese Erkenntnisse, wurde gefragt, ja, was sind denn das für Erkenntnisse? Da war die Frage, gibt es schon vorgefasste Begrifflichkeiten, die vor dem Einwirken der Phänomene der Welt in unserem vernunftverarbeiteten Informationssystem schon quasi, wie nennt sich das, firmwaremäßig implementiert sind?
Man muss da auch erstmal eine Deutungssprache finden, sozusagen.
Ja, das geht um die Frage, ob quasi in der Vernunft schon ein Vorwissen über die möglichen Phänomene, die als Fragestellung auf die Vernunft eintreffen wird, schon vorgegeben sind. Da haben die Rationalisten gesagt, ja, es gibt in der Ratio, in der Vernunft, schon von Gott, von wem auch immer, von der Genetik quasi voreingegebene Kategorien, die wie im Rechner, die Ports, gewissermaßen die Anfragen schon in die richtigen Kanäle leiten.
Welche Kategorien soll das dann sein?
Das könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass blau eine Farbe ist und halt kein Zustand.
Also eine grundlegende Terminologie.
Ja, ohne die man gar nicht die wirklich wichtigen Fragen beantworten kann. Die Gegenposition war der Empirismus, der gesagt hat, das bildet sich alles durch die Einwirkungen von außen. Die Wirklichkeit, das was nämlich von außen auf uns, die wir das alles erleiden müssen, wir, das Subjekt, das Geworfene in diese Wirklichkeit, die muss diesen Informationsschauer aussetzen. Der Empirismus hat so ein bisschen das Problem, dass er dann nie so genau klar machen konnte, wie sich dieser Selektionsprozess, dieses Filtering in den Sinnen wirklich bilden konnte. Und Immanuel Kant hat eine dann relativ gute Kompromissformel gebildet, die ich jetzt an dieser Stelle gar nicht weiter ausbringen will. Auf jeden Fall war es erst mal relativ zufriedenstellend für alle Seiten, sodass man dann, kleine Anekdote, Immanuel Kant wollte eigentlich ganz andere Dinge philosophisch begründen. Und dann kam ihm aber genau dieses Problem dazwischen. Was ist eigentlich das Instrument, mit dem ich meine Urteile begründe? Was ist das eigentlich? Bevor ich nicht weiß, wie dieser Apparat, mit dem ich all diese Fragen jetzt später mal beantworten werde, bevor ich den nicht genau definieren kann, kann ich mir auch nicht sicher sein, dass ich die Antworten zum Thema, was ist der ewige Friede, was darf ich hoffen, was darf ich tun, also welche Sitte und welche Moral muss ich anderen Menschen empfehlen. Da muss ich erstmal Kenntnis darüber bekommen, nach welchen Mechanismen dieser Apparat funktioniert. Und da hat er sich für elf Jahre zurückgezogen und hat keine einzige Veröffentlichung gebracht.
Warte mal, wer jetzt? Kant?
Kant. Der war schon recht berühmt und hatte eine Professorenstelle und man denkt ja an einen Professor, dann wird er veröffentlichten oder zumindest lehren. Nein, Immanuel Kant war elf Jahre lang geschwiegen und kam dann mit diesem quasi epochemachenden, historischen Kompromiss, den er selbst als die pernikanische Wende der Philosophie bezeichnet hat, kam auf den Tisch und hat gesagt, jetzt kann ich daran gehen, mein Programm zu erledigen. Das heißt, das, was er eigentlich wollte. Und dieses Werk hieß, glaube ich, Kritik der Reinvernunft. Und das ist quasi so was wie der absolute Höhepunkt einer bestimmten abendländischen Philosophie, die irgendwie von den alten Griechen über Platon, Thomas von Aquin, Augustinus, auch die römischen Philosophen, die konnten alle quasi, man konnte sich dann quasi in diesem überzeitlichen Gespräch da auf einigen Kanten hat hier echt eine tolle Integrationsleistung geleistet, hinsichtlich dieses Problem der Vernunft als das entscheidende Kriterium, nach dem Wissen geordnet wird. Und was auch allen Menschen, ob die nun schwarz oder weiß, groß oder klein oder sonst wie, es gibt ein gemeinsames Merkmal und das ist diese Vernunft, die bildigen wir allen Menschen zu. Und damit kommt so ein Universitätsanspruch, der auch dazu führt, dass der Mensch eben nicht mehr nur der europäische Mensch ist gegenüber den wilden Barbaren, die man quasi zu beherrschen hat, wie so Halbtiere. Das hat natürlich ein paar Jahrhunderte gedauert. Eigentlich ist es dann ja auch erst am letzten Donnerstag gewissermaßen zu einem vorläufigen Ende gekommen, als ein schwarzer Präsidentschaftskandidat im Tiergarten gesprochen hat.
Ach echt, so eine Zeitenwende war das? Das war mir jetzt noch gar nicht bewusst.
Nee, es ist eine Vollendung. Die Zeitenwende war ja schon viel früher, aber bis zur letzten Instanz, und auch damit obersten Instanz durch, spricht dieser Emanzipationsprozess von Bevölkerungsgruppen, die vorher als nicht satisfaktionsfähig und als nicht geeignet gewesen wären, dass man sich unter sie als obersten Befehlshaber der Armee zum Beispiel stellt oder als Führer der westlichen Welt stellt.
Noch ist er nicht gewählt, also die Sache kann sich noch ein bisschen rauszuhören. Ich muss jetzt mal, weil es so meine Art ist, weil ich das auch für Angemessenheit mal ein bisschen zurückspulen, um auch selber nochmal zu sicherzustellen, dass ich dem Gespräch korrekt folgen kann. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch schon eine ganze Menge. Wir sind jetzt von der Analyse des Auftretens der Postmoderne und den Faktoren, die da irgendwie sichtbar waren, dahinter gegriffen haben, rübergeschwenkt zur Philosophie, festgehalten, dass die Philosophie über lange, lange Zeit irgendwie sehr statisch war und in Aussagen sich erwirtschaftet hat, die über lange Zeit anwendbar waren.
Nee.
Hast du aber gesagt.
Ich habe das gesagt, aber als Unterfütterung, um zu zeigen, wenn ich sage, es gibt etwas wie Postmoderne, dann gibt es ja auch etwas wie die Moderne. Und die Postmoderne können wir nur dann verstehen als Distanzierung von der Moderne, wenn wir einen Begriff, einen gemeinsamen Begriff entwickeln, was denn eigentlich die Moderne ist.
Genau, da bist du auf die Philosophie eingestellt.
Genau, weil durch die philosophische Tätigkeit quasi dieses ganze Fundament ins Rutschen gekommen ist, den du als dynamischen Prozess beschrieben hast. Und durch die Philosophie hat sich der Mensch emanzipiert vom Aberglauben, von einer unkritischen Religion im Sinne von wenn es blitzt und donnert, dann hat der Donnergott zugeschlagen und ich hab Angst. Die monotheistischen Religionen haben ja nur alle Götter quasi verdrängt und durch eine einzelne Instanz ersetzt. Aber Aberglaube ist es geblieben. Die Aufklärung hat dafür gesorgt, dass Gott, wenn überhaupt zur Privatsache wird, zu einer außerhalb der Welt, da von mir aus letztbegründenden, aber letztlich auch unerheblichen Instanz geworden ist, an die man nur noch glaubt, aber von der man nicht mehr weiß. Und das ist eine wichtige Wende. Weil vorher war Gott nicht eine Glaubensfrage, sondern das war eine Tatsache. Und jetzt ist er nur noch eine Möglichkeit.
So ein Hobby.
Auf jeden Fall ist es ein Hobby.
So wie Kleingärtnerei, Kegelklub.
Ja, also die Frage nach der Letzbegründung ist natürlich nach wie vor da. Das hat ja nichts mit Kleingärtnerei zu tun. Also CERN ist ja kein Kleingarten, wo Monstermaschinen gebaut werden, um an die Grenze dieser letzten Fragen zu kommen. Aber wir kommen dem Begriff der Moderne jetzt sehr, sehr gut nahe. Und wir kommen jetzt bei Kant, der diese Vernunftdimension, die sich emanzipiert hat, von allen anderen Erscheinungen der Welt. Das heißt, was vorher Gott gewesen ist, ist jetzt die Vernunft. Damit brauchen wir Gott nicht mehr. Den schieben wir in diese Hobbie-Ecke ab.
Aber jetzt kommt die Vernunft in die Kritik.
Ja, wenn er sagt, Kritik ist, was heute Abhandlung heißt. Also Kritik nicht im Sinne, wie wir Kritik heute nehmen. Kritik, der rein von uns ist, ist eine Abhandlung über. Also das ist so ein bisschen...
Das ist ein Teil des Diskurses.
Die Kritik kam eine andere. Nämlich, dass die Vernunft sich selbst gegenüber gar nicht transparent ist. Was aber Kant durchaus tut.
Vernunft ist sich selbst gegenüber nicht transparent. Was meinst du damit?
Das meine ich. Das Kant, der Meinung ist, er macht ein für ihn zufriedenstellendes, ihn zufriedenstellendes, auch die Welt zufriedenstellendes Werk, die Kritik der reinen Vernunft, wo er selber und auch alle anderen, oder die meisten anderen, das Gefühl haben, ja, der hat es erfasst. Da hat einer mal gesagt, was die Vernunft, und zwar als allgemeines Prinzip, denn so ist. Und jetzt kommen andere und sagen, also das meine ich mit Transparenz. Das heißt, er hat das ja mit seiner individuellen Verstandesleistung, dem Idealtyp der Vernunft, weil deswegen ist er so ein Genie, fast so nahe gekommen ist, dass er gewissermaßen, dass die Vernunft als ein allgemeines Prinzip mal in eine Definition hat bringen können. Und jetzt kommt die Kritik. Ich glaube, Herder, ein deutscher Philosoph, ein Zeitgenosse, ein Schüler, glaube ich, auch von Kant, hat den entscheidenden Einspruch erhoben, hinsichtlich der Verdunklung der Vernunft gegenüber sich selbst, also dass es nicht transparent ist. Er hat nämlich gesagt, lieber Immanuel Kant, deine Kritik der reinen Vernunft hast du ja letztlich auch nur in der deutschen Sprache geschrieben. Wie kannst du eigentlich sicher sein, dass dein Instrument Sprache so hinreichend ist, dass es die doch eigentlich übergeordnete Kategorie Vernunft angemessen repräsentieren kann?
Ist das so die Frage, ob man auch in anderen Sprachen vernünftig sein kann?
Nein, das ist die Frage nach dem Henne und dem Ei. Die Vernunft hat Gott ersetzt. Gott brauchte sich noch nicht wem gegenüber den Rechenschaft abzuliefern, in welcher Art er spricht und wem gegenüber, weil dazu war Gott. Die Vernunft kann ja vernünftigerweise gegenüber der Welt nur urteilen, wenn sie letztlich auch eine Selbstkritik fähig ist. In dem formalen Logikprogramm tut sie das ja schon. Da stellt sie Sätze auf und guckt, ob die Regeln sich in allen möglichen Varianten auch immer wieder so eintreffen und rekursive. Da aber diese formale Logik keine Entsprechung hat in der natürlichen Welt, ist das in seinem Formalismus leerlaufend. Deswegen im Sinne von Trainingsprogramm. In der Anwendung auf die wirkliche Welt hat Kant versucht, sich gewissermaßen des Aufbaus der Vernunft klar zu werden. Aber beschreiben kann er das nur mit einem weltlichen Instrument, nämlich die Sprache. Diese Sprache ist als weltliches Instrument doch gerade das, gehört doch zur Dersphäre an, wo die Vernunft ihr eigentlich übergeordnet ist. Weil die Vernunft ist ja allen Phänomenen, geistigen, kulturellen, realen Phänomenen, übergeordnet. Und trotzdem muss sie sich in dieser dreckigen, schmutzigen Welt eines schmutzigen Codes benutzen, um sich selbst in voller Schönheit darzustellen. Ja, da ist doch ein möglicher Methodenfehler zu erkennen. Und dieser Methodenfehler nennt sich the linguistic term in der Philosophie.
Aha, im Sinne von Wende?
Ja, denn seitdem sind alle philosophischen Probleme erstmal Sprachprobleme. Das heißt, wir würden das alles gerne so anerkennen, aber es gibt einen hinreichenden Zweifel hinsichtlich der uns zur Verfügung stehenden beschreibenden Mittel. Diesen Zweifel können wir so nicht ausräumen. Wir müssen uns erstmal mit der Sprache beschäftigen, bevor wir uns überhaupt wieder der Vernunft zuwenden, um die Vernunft als Maschine zu gebrauchen, die dann die uns drängenden Fragen beantworten soll.
Da sind ja die Mathematiker fast nichts dagegen. Das ist ja wirklich krass, krasse Definitionskettenkrieg.
Das ist jetzt nur von einem Laien, wenn unter den Hörern ein philosophisch geschulter Mensch ist, dann wird er wahrscheinlich nur mitleidig lächeln, darüber, wie viele Sachen ich jetzt gerade hier verschleife.
Du meinst, wie viele weitere Untiefen da noch lauern.
Und an diesem Punkt, also diesen grundsätzlichen Unbehagen, setzt auch das an, was Poststrukturalismus betreibt. Aber er hat zwei Geschwister. Das heißt, es haben sich aus dieser grundsätzlichen Fragestellung oder Problematik mit der Sprache drei verschiedene Lösungsstrategien entwickelt. Die eine ist die analytische Sprachphilosophie. Die ist insbesondere im angelsächsischen Raum so prägnant, dass all das, was hier in Europa passiert, einfach nur die Continental-Philosophie heißt.
Ah, also wie Continental Breakfast.
Genau, das ist so das andere. Die haben diesen typisch sympathischen angloamerikanischen Ansatz, dass sie einfach mal sagen, where's the beef? Und sagen, ja, diese Verdunklung der Sprache, das lösen wir, indem wir uns einfach anschauen, in welchen konkreten Situationen sprechen die Leute, was meinen die damit? Wir gehen vom Common Sense aus und diese ganzen überbordenden Kategorien, Türme im Elfenbein von Kant und den ganzen deutschen Idealisten, das ist alles ziemliches Geschwafel.
Das hält uns nur von der Arbeit ab.
Das hält uns von der Arbeit ab. Wir lichten jetzt mal dieses Gestrüpp und wenn wir nur hinreichend diese ganzen wuchernden Missinterpretationen und Unklarheiten wegschneiden, dann kommen wir zu einem klaren englischen Garten der Philosophie, in der jedes Hecke seinen genauen Sitz und Platz hat, der Rasen schön kurz ist und folglich auch entsprechend in seiner Ästhetik intellektuellen Ansprüchen genügt. Das ist die analytische Philosophie. Die andere, die ist mehr auf der deutschen Seite, das ist die Hermeneutik. Abgeleitet von Hermes, dem Götterboten, der uns die Mitteilungen, die Nachrichten bringt.
Die Kommunikation.
Die Hermeneutik glaubt, trotz der prinzipiell angezweifelten Möglichkeit der Sprache uns die Wahrheit zu bringen. Sie hat nämlich schon die Idee, die Sprache ist ja nur ein System. Und dieses System lebt ja schon von Abstraktionen. Im Sinne von, jede Regel hat eine Anwendung. Und alle Anwendungen müssen ja in einer Regel wieder subsumiert werden. Und ist nicht in dieser Abstraktion eigentlich schon so etwas wie, auch schon theoretisch ein Beschneiden drin, was die anderen, die Sprachanalytiker, die forsten gewissermaßen die direkte Anwendung aus auf bestimmte Begrifflichkeiten. Die Hermäneutiker sagen, baut mal euren englischen Garten, aber ich schau mir die einzelne Pflanze an, den einzelnen Spross, die einzelne Knospe. Und die findet ihr in eurem Regelsystem garantiert nicht. Der Einzelfall verhält sich immer als individuelles in einer gewissen Opposition oder in Kongruenz zu den Regelfällen, zu den Tokens innerhalb des theoretischen Systems. Und wenn also das Sprachsystem möglicherweise kontaminiert ist, weil es innerweltliche Problematik hat, können wir trotzdem im Einzelfall einen Sinn hinter dem System entdecken.
Das heißt, man kann auch ohne System deuten?
Man kann hinter dem System deuten.
Hinter dem System?
Man muss sich bücken, muss die Hecke öffnen, den die Regel gewissermaßen nicht in ihrer Regelhaftigkeit, sondern in ihrer konkreten, weltlichen Verästelung anschauen und hat dann die Möglichkeit, an bestimmten, und zwar über einen langwierigen Prozess, Wahrheitskerne zu erkennen. Das ist die Amelieutik.
Muss man das jetzt beliebig, muss man nun eine möglichst große Lupe zum Ansatz bringen oder muss ich wirklich da auch schon die Matrix auseinanderreißen und dahinter schauen?
Von der Metapher her würde ich dir sagen, die Lupe.
Okay, das heißt, das Detail kann abweichen vom ganzen System. Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Ausnahme, bestätigt die Regel.
Ja, das ist aber so ein ziemlich unfilosophisches...
Tut mir leid, ich bin unfilosophisch.
Ja, es gibt ganz viele alltagssprachliche Dinge.
Vielleicht kommt das ja da her.
Dass du als Tim Pritlove natürlich der angelsächsischen Sprachanalyse folgen würdest, ist mir ja klar.
Nein, ich bin totally unbiased. Mir ist es egal.
Du hast aber noch eine schöne Metapher gebracht mit die Struktur zerreißen. Das ist dann der Poststrukturalismus. Das heißt, der hat nämlich ein prinzipielles Problem mit Sinnhaftigkeit. Der sagt, nicht nur das System kann sich nur dadurch stabilisieren, dass es Reduktionen in der wirklichen Welt vornimmt. Also Idealtypen erzeugen Idealfälle. Die Regeln können nur durch Ideen in Idealen. Die Regel muss strikt befolgt werden und kann dann nur in einer Besonderheit auftauchen, die immer wieder rekursiv ist und sich immer wieder wiederholen kann. Eine Regel kann immer nur eine bestimmte Form von Anwendung zur Folge haben.
Also nicht die Ausnahme bestätigt die Regel, sondern die Ausnahme ist die Regel.
Ich krieg das momentan noch nicht in meinen Gedanken hinein.
Verzeih mir meine plumpen Versuche, das runterzubrechen. Aber jetzt mach ich einfach mal das, was ich am liebsten mache, und versuche mal wieder ein bisschen zusammenzufassen. Also wir waren jetzt irgendwie bei Herrn Kant. Herr Kant hat irgendwie das Ich hinterfragt und viel über die Vernunft philosophiert, die er nun Gott abgelöst hat. Und auf einmal war die ganze Philosophie dabei, sich darüber zu streiten, was denn nun das beste Regelwerk ist, um das alles zu deuten. Und die Amerikaner haben einfach diesen europäischen Elfenbeinturm-Diskussion, die so ein bisschen sich an Details und Set-ups orientiert hat, links liegen gelassen. Und hat einfach gesagt, wir schaffen jetzt hier einfach mal auf Basis eines, wie sagtest du so schön, auf Basis des Kommenzenzda unsere Bilder. Und ordnen uns jetzt mal die Welt schön mit irgendwelchen Regeln. Wie sind denn diese Regeln dann überhaupt aufgestellt worden? Also ich meine, was für Regeln waren denn das? Also war das jetzt, ich meine, war das wirklich was Konkretes? Die Philosophie ist immer so unglaublich unkonkret. Das ist ja wie so ein Fisch im Bach, den man versucht zu greifen und der die ganze Zeit hinterherflutscht und sagt so nie, so einfach ist es nicht. Ich muss jetzt noch mal kurz nach oben schwimmen.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass das Instrument gleichzeitig sein Material ist. Du zezierst quasi mit einem lebenden Objekt dich selbst.
Das ist Software im besten Sinne.
Der wichtigste Aspekt ist die Verdunklung, also die Problematisierung der Sprache. Eine Verdunklung würdest du das nennen? Ja, im Sinne von Nichttransparenz.
Wer war denn das, der das so verdunkelt hat?
Das ist eine Kritik, das heißt, das ist ein Vorwurf, ein Zweifel an der Arbeit, die mit Kant zu einem vorläufigen Abschluss gekommen ist und die im Prinzip eine affirmative, mit sich im Reinen sehende Auffassung davon hat, was vernünftig ist. Und nach wie vor, diese Botschaft konnte in die Welt und auch erarbeitet worden, also die hat eine gewisse Transzendenz, die steht über allen Urteilen, über allen Erfahrungen, diese Vernunft als Idealtyp. Und sie kann aber nur mit schmutzigen, weltlichen Mitteln beschrieben und gedacht werden. Weil die Sprache ist ja nicht nur was Äußerliches, die Sprache ist ja auch in uns. Das ist jetzt noch der wesentlich brisantere Verdunkelungsaspekt. Also die Idee nämlich, unsere Gedanken wären rein, nur das Ausdrucksmittel Sprache wäre kontaminiert durch weltliche Aspekte, die ist zu kurz gefasst. Denn in unserer Sprachentwicklung nehmen wir ja diese Sprache aus der Welt auf und eignen sie uns an. Daraus kommt dieses Henne-Ei Problem im Sinne von spricht die Sprache als System mich? Und wie soll ich als Individuum das überhaupt erst in der Sprache, dem sich mir Einschreibenden durch Übung, durch Training in mir aufgenommenen System, wie soll ich da Gedanken fassen, die über dieses System hinausgehen? Das geht ja gar nicht. Daraus kommt diese grundsätzliche Verdunklung hinsichtlich der Frage, ist das nicht, wenn man eine absolute Vernunftskategorie aufstellt, die über allen Dingen ist, bewegt man sich doch in einem unaufhebbaren Widerspruch? Diesem Widerspruch begegnete diese drei Antworten, die Sprachanalyse der Engländer, die gesagt haben, das interessiert uns jetzt, das ist mal ein Scheiß. Weil im Alltag funktioniert es ja. Jetzt bleiben wir mal wirklich pragmatisch im Sinne von, in der Anwendung klappt es doch. Und daraus machen wir nach ganz normalen, uns wissenschaftlich zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln, werden wir dieses Problem lösen. Und bleiben bei dem systemischen Gedanken. Die Hermeneutik sagt, die Systeme sind auch nur innerhalb dieser nicht metaphysisch begründeten Formation denkbar. Die stehen nicht außerhalb der realen Welt. Und die reale Welt ist nicht nur die materielle, sondern auch die kulturelle und die sprachliche Welt. Aber wir sind trotzdem überzeugt, dass wir im Einzelfall, nämlich in dieser Bandbreite der Phänomene, die letztlich nur nach bestimmten Schwellwerten in Kategorien geformt werden. Ich bin sicher, dass man sogar das einzelne Bit, wenn man sich von der Elektronenladung anguckt, kleine Unterschiede finden könnte, dass man auf einem Rechner einen Code bringen könnte, der hinter dem Schwellwert von dem, was ein Bit ist und was kein Bit ist, durchaus Informationen codieren kann. Das ist Hermeneutik. Und die dritte Antwort des Poststrukturalismus sagt, selbst in dieser Idee hinter dem System noch Sinn zu vermuten, ist schon dadurch abzulehnen, weil da eine Präsenz hinter dem kontaminierten System wieder aufgebaut wird, die wieder außerhalb des Systems ist.
Vielleicht noch mal um den Zeitkontext klarzumachen. Wir sind jetzt irgendwie von Kant aufgebrochen, das ist ja nun schon lange her, aber dieses Phänomen des Poststrukturalismus, was du jetzt beschreibst, was sozusagen dann diesen pragmatischen Ansatz der Philosophen in der Nachfolge von Kant versucht wieder auf den Kopf zu stellen. Wann hat denn das eingesetzt?
Also, Kant Ende des 18. Jahrhunderts, die erste Kritik an der sprachlichen Problematik kam sofort, also Ende des 18. Jahrhunderts. Durch das 19. Jahrhundert wurde dann die Sprachdimension von sehr vielen Philosophen immer wieder aufgenommen, sodass man sagen kann, es gibt Vorläufer. Ich hatte ja vorhin erwähnt, also alle Philosophie tritt quasi überzeitlich auch mit sich selber ins Gespräch, weil diese Grundfragen sich immer wieder jeder Generation wieder stellen können. Und deswegen ist jetzt die poststrukturalistische Philosophie nicht so aus nichts entstanden, sondern die hat sich in der Auseinandersetzung mit Philosophen des 19. Jahrhunderts, insbesondere zum Beispiel Nietzsche und dann Heidegger und dann über Französische, bald sei dann letztlich erst mal ein französisches Phänomen war, dort etabliert in einer kritischen Auseinandersetzung, dass Schüler ein Lehrgebäude entdeckt haben und natürlich gesagt haben, hey, da ist doch was hohl, da klopfe ich mal gegen. Und diese Einzelkritiken, die sind gewissermaßen dann so evident geworden, dass man von dem Poststrukturalismus spricht, eben erst in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts. Und es ist ein Denken, dass quasi den klassischen, modernen Kategorien zuwiderläuft und es kritisiert.
Warum tut es das? Das ist mir nicht ganz klar. Also wir haben jetzt diese ganzen Post-Kant-Philosophen, die sich allerlei weitere Kategorien zugelegt haben, wie die Hermeneutik und so weiter. Fasst man das jetzt alles unter Strukturalismus zusammen? Oder alles lässt sich klar deuten? Alles hat irgendwie klare Strukturen? Wenn es da einen Poststrukturalismus gibt, dann muss ja auch ein Strukturalismus gegeben haben.
Ganz kurz, der Strukturalismus ist eine Erweiterung, einer reinen Sprach- und Zeichentheorie, die erstmal noch gar nicht philosophisch angelegt war, sondern sich wirklich stärker in der Sprachwissenschaft entwickelt hat. Und die dabei aufgenommenen Mechanismen, die für die Beschreibung der Sprachsysteme als nützlich empfunden worden sind, sind übernommen worden für andere Texte, die halt nicht mehr reine Sprachen, sondern Texte im Sinne von Handlungen, Institutionen, Menschen. Du kannst ja alles, was Menschen tun, auch eine Zuschreibung machen. Das heißt, auf einmal, die gesamte Gesellschaft, die gesamte Welt wurde als Sprache, als Text empfunden. Und man hat gesagt, wir nehmen jetzt einfach das, was sich in der Sprachtheorie als nützlich erwiesen hat, und erweitern dies auf das Feld der gesamten Kultur. Und mit diesem Ausgriff aus der reinen Sprachtheorie ist sie gewissermaßen in die Philosophie hinübergewandert. Und die Philosophie, wie wir eben gesehen haben, hatte ja schon ein Problem mit der Sprache. Das heißt, die haben natürlich auch geguckt, was machen denn die eigentlichen Grammatiker, die Leute, die Linguisten, die Philologen.
Das heißt, auf der Suche nach Werkzeugen zur Deutung ihrer eigenen Denkerei haben sie sich dann einfach bei den Linguisten bedient und haben gesagt, ah super, ihr habt ja ja schon einen Werkzeugkasten, vielleicht können wir den ja mal ein bisschen aufbauen. Und damit waren sie dann aber eine Weile glücklich.
Glücklich, glücklich war da niemand sonst.
Das glaube ich, das ist wohl das Schicksal des Philosophs, dass in dem Moment, wo er glücklich ist, keiner seinen Beruf wechseln. Aber gut, das heißt, dieser Poststrukturalismus lehnt eigentlich diese klare Deutung ab.
Ja, er lehnt eine außerhalb eines Textes sich befindliche Instanz, die in irgendeiner Form Einfluss nehmen kann auf das, was da im Text passiert, lehnt sie ab.
Ignoriert alle Regeln.
Indy, die Regeln, die gibt es innerhalb des Textes schon, aber es gibt keine über- und außerhalb stehende Instanz, die die Regeln gewissermaßen setzen könnte.
Jetzt kommt die eigentliche Herausforderung für dich, weil wir befinden uns ja jetzt hier in den letzten 15 Minuten, da diese Sendung von Chaosradio Live ist, haben wir quasi die Zielgerade vor Augen. Und jetzt müssen wir mal zu klaren Beispielen kommen.
Das ist toll, gerade wenn das Thema spannend wird und wir das Gefühl haben, wir sind im Thema, ist die Zeit vorbei.
Ja, ich will nicht nur sozusagen das Finale einläuten, weil es muss ja nun auch ein bisschen greifbarer werden. Wir haben jetzt einen relativ ausufernden Diskurs durch die philosophische Zeitgeschichte gemacht. Und das ist natürlich alles. Damit, wie man gehört hat, kämpft die Philosophie gerade wirklich mit der Nicht-Greifbarkeit ihrer eigentlichen Thesen oder Beweisbarkeit oder was auch immer.
Sie ist momentan, sie hat das Problem, dass ihr Arbeitsmittel braun geworden ist.
Braun?
Braun. Im Sinne von...
Scheiße.
Es ist opark.
Es sollte aber möglichst glasklar sein...
Ah, verstehe. Es ist sozusagen getrübt.
Die Vernunft oder diese Letztinstanz, die wir jedem Menschen zuordnen und das gemeinsame, übergeordnete Kriterium, mit der alle Erkenntnis nur verarbeitet werden kann, wird in der Kategorie der Vernunft gebündelt. Die fassen wir jetzt mal als Apparat. Diese Vernunft muss auch in irgendeinem Verhältnis zu sich selber zu urteilen kommen. Also einer Reflektion, einer Repräsentation. Denn wenn sie sich gegenüber sich selbst nicht rechenschaft ablegen kann, wie soll sie denn dann vernünftige Urteile über den Rest der Welt äußern? Und an der Stelle, das kann sie aber nur mittels der Sprache. Aber eigentlich ist sie doch der Sprache übergeordnet. Weil die Sprache ist ein Teil dieser Phänomene, für die die Vernunft eigentlich gedacht ist, dass sie sie zu beurteilen hätte. Und damit kommen wir also in einen erstmal nicht lösbaren Widerspruch. Die die Vernunft jetzt anzweifeln lässt. Nochmal, die pragmatische Philosophie hat gesagt, das interessiert uns nicht, wir halten das für Sophismus. Also das ist so Prinzipienreiterei. Im Alltag klappt es. Die Hermeneutik sagt, wir akzeptieren das. Wir glauben aber, dass es gewissermaßen Bedeutungskerne gibt, die auch nicht von der Weltlichkeit kontaminiert sind. Also sowas wie eine Wahrheit ist möglich, wenn auch nur mit einem sehr starken Lupe erkennbar. Und der Poststrukturalismus sagt, solange es jemand gibt, der meint, eine Lupe benutzen zu müssen, gibt es jemanden, der sich außerhalb des Systems stellt. Und wer sich außerhalb des Systems stellt, der macht sich zu einem Art Gott und behauptet nicht mehr in diesen Gesamtzusammenhang Welt eingewoben zu sein. Woher nimmt er diese Gewissheit, nicht Teil dieser Welt zu sein und sich gewissermaßen in eine Kategorie, und sei es auch nur die Vernunft, dass sie über den Dingen schwebt. Also der Poststrukturalismus sagt, es gibt nichts außerhalb des Textes. Und damit ist alles relativ. Und hier komme ich vielleicht nochmal zu dieser Metapher aus der Physik. Das heißt, was ich jetzt über die Philosophie gesagt habe, das ist so die klassische Newtonische Physik. Und dieser Poststrukturalismus ist so etwas, wie die Quantenmechanik sich dazu verhält. In der klassischen Physik würde man auch sagen, was interessiert mich die Quantenmechanik? Mit Newtons Formeln kann ich wirklich 99% meiner Alltagsphänomene berechnen und der Fahrstuhl hält und fällt nicht runter. Also bitte, was soll der Scheiß? Und da mag ja was sein. Es gibt aber auch so, wie Einstein gesagt hat, der hat ein grundsätzliches Missfallen an dieser Möglichkeit, die sich in der Quantenmechanik eröffnet hat, dass er gesagt hat, Gott würfelt nicht. Und dieser Poststrukturalismus eröffnet eine Kategorie, in der gesagt wird, letztlich gibt es keine Wahrheit, sondern Sinnzusammenhänge ergeben sich innerhalb von diskursiven Sprachspielen, das heißt von Bedeutungszusammenhängen, die sich gegenüber anderen absetzen. Und wenn die eine gewisse Evidenz haben, dann können die für eine Zeit lang als Bedeutung, als Sinn bestehen, aber sie haben keine Wahrheit im absoluten Sinne, keine Richtigkeit in jedem Sinne, sondern sie sind immer nur in ihrem jeweiligen Kontext wahr, aber nicht in einem philosophisch überzeitlich absoluten, aus der Geschichte quasi durch formale Logik zu enthebenden Sinne Wahrheit.
Es gibt keine absolute Wahrheit?
Ja.
Was meinte denn Einstein genau, weil er gesagt hat, Gott würfelt nicht?
Da musst du deinen Haus- und Hofphysiker fragen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie interpretierst du das jetzt so philosophisch?
Gut, das Problem war doch bei der Quantenmechanik, dass dort Dinge aufgetreten sind, dass man, wenn man genau hinguckt, auf einmal Dinge nicht mehr genau beschreibbar war. Zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt konntest du nicht sagen, wo das Elektron ist. Oder wenn du sagen konntest, wo es ist, konntest du nicht mehr den Zeitpunkt nennen.
Die Beobachtung verfälscht die Messung.
Das habe ich auch so gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob aber nicht das Theoretische...
Aber das Beobachtende ist natürlich rein physikalisch auch schon beeinflusst.
Ja, Sinn finden könnte man ja auch in dem Sinne als ein Verfahren bezeichnen, das in irgendeiner Form Spuren hinterlässt im Gegenstand dessen, was es da betrachten will.
Also die Poststrukturalisten stellen ein altes, sich über viele Jahrhunderte langsam entwickelndes philosophisches Grundbild infrage. Wer sind denn da so die Vertreter und welche Auswirkungen hat das für uns?
Alle. Wie alle. Das Tolle ist ja, dass die Poststrukturalisten in der Meinung sind, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt haben alle noch sogenannte metaphysische Einschlüsse. Also irgendwo in ihrem Denken gibt es noch, und sei es auf der Ebene des Zeichenbegriffs, also die Zeichentheorie ist ein bisschen das, was die Elementarteilchenphysiker so beschreiben wollen, auf der Ebene der Kulturwissenschaften. Also es sind so quasi die Quarks oder zumindest was hinter den Atomen sich so wie. Das ist Zeichenbegriff drin. Und genauso wie die Elementarphysiker, die Kosmologie anhand dessen erkunden können, indem sie die Atome zertrümmern, so kann man, gibt es mal das kleinste Prinzip, in der Sinn sich manifestiert, wenn man den sich genau anguckt, kann man darüber auch Aussagen hinsichtlich zu allen, sich daraus ausfaltenden Sinnzusammenhängen entwickeln. Und das ist eben die Welt an und für sich, die wir erfahren können, weil es gibt keine Welt außerhalb einer beschreibbaren Welt. Und damit ist alles Text und alles Literatur und alles letztlich auch mit literaturwissenschaftlichen Methoden zu untersuchen.
Das ist zu untersuchen?
Es hat sich insofern, das was man mit einem gewissen Zufriedenheit in der Linguistik ansetzen kann, um Sprache zu beschreiben, kann man eben dann in einer Skalierung auch benutzen, um Institutionen zu beschreiben, um Ideologien zu beschreiben, um Lebensformen zu beschreiben, um Geschichte zu beschreiben. Nichts ist mehr davor sicher von Literaturwissenschaftlern analysiert zu werden. Das heißt, eine Philosophie wird durch diesen Linguistik-Turn zu allererst mal zu einem Anwendungsfall von Sprachwissenschaft.
Im Vorfeld hast du gesagt, dass man, wenn man auf den Poststrukturalismus blickt, letzten Endes feststellt, dass unsere Welt wesentlich seltsamer und unheimlicher ist, als unsere Eltern uns immer haben weiß machen wollen. Wie passt denn das jetzt zusammen?
Das passt dahin zusammen, dass es keine letzten Gewissheiten mehr gibt, dass ein Emanzipationsschema im Sinne zur Sonne, zur Freiheit sich brechen kann, weil es als eine Ideologie enttarnt worden ist, die nicht mehr einem absoluten Prinzip folgen muss, weil es keine absoluten Prinzipien mehr gibt. Und jetzt wird es deswegen eben auch zu einem gefährlichen Denken, weil, wo ist denn dann das Gute in der Welt? Und sei es nur als Ideal, dem man doch vernünftigerweise sich verpflichtet fühlen könnte, und für das man bereit ist zu kämpfen, das sind doch Werte, nicht nur Normen. Und wenn der Poststrukturalismus sagt, ne ne, das sind alles nur Fiktionen, dann gibt es, zumindest auf der theoretischen Ebene, auch keinen Einspruch gegen das Böse. Und das ist etwas, was dem Poststrukturalismus vorgeworfen wird, dass er einen Werte-Relativismus betreibt. Dass alle vorhergehenden Setzungen immer einen Kompromiss zwischen den widerstreitenden Interessen voraussetzen konnte, weil man sich ja einigen konnte, in unserer Vernunft sind wir uns doch alle gleich. Und wenn wir uns mal vernünftigerweise um einen runden Tisch setzen würden und die jeweiligen Probleme aussortieren, dann müssten wir doch alle zumindest theoretisch in der Lage sein, zu einem gemeinsamen Konsens zu finden. Und wenn wir uns das, was natürlich nie gelingt, aber wenn wir uns das zumindest als Ideal, als gesellschaftliches Ideal zur Konfliktbewältigung immer wieder vor Augen führen würden, was ja in der Nachwendezeit mit den runden Tischen genau passiert ist, dann gibt es eine Chance für ein Prinzip oder die Möglichkeit, dass die Dinge sich zum Guten wenden. Aber wenn man sich auf ein solches übergeordnetes Prinzip nicht mehr berufen kann, dann gibt es unter Umständen auch nicht die Möglichkeit, dass man sagt, nein, Vernunft ist sowieso nur eine Zuschreibung. Die gibt es ja gar nicht. Ich will bestimmte Leute einfach nicht hier haben, weil ob die Vernunft haben oder nicht, das ist ja nur eine Zuschreibung. Ich finde, die stinken und deswegen möchte ich die nicht am Tisch haben. Die sind deswegen nicht leicht. Die sind für mich nicht diskursfähig. Ich möchte mich mit denen gar nicht unterhalten. Und vorher konnte man mit einem absoluten Kriterium sagen, ne, ne, auch der hat ja entsprechend die Vernunft. Und dieser Werterelativismus gehört zu den Dingen, die den Poststrukturalismus und damit auch die Postmoderne an und für sich diskreditiert haben. Und das ist auch nach wie vor nicht ausreichend diskutiert, ob das jetzt was Gutes oder was Schlechtes ist. Wie geht dieses Denken mit diesen unguten Möglichkeiten um?
Gregor, das war eine dicke Packung. Jetzt sind wir am Ende. Wir müssen zum Ende kommen. Hast du noch einen letzten, kurzen, zusammenfassenden Satz?
Ja, ich möchte ganz gerne in Französisch sagen, wir sollten eine Fortsetzung machen.
Ich spüre das auch. Ich hoffe, dass wir da einen guten Titel finden. Hat gerade so eben reingepasst. Ich hätte jetzt noch einige Fragen. Aber wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, wir werden es weiter diskutieren. Und zwar im Internet, im Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Das auf jeden Fall findet ihr den Eintrag zu dieser Sendung. Chaosradio Express, Nummer 91 war das. Und dieses Feedback ist wie immer gern gesehen. Wenn ihr sonstige Fragen habt, chaosradio.ccc.de, könnt ihr euch auch per E-Mail an uns wenden. Aber gerade im Blog ist die offene Diskussion gern gesehen. Ansonsten für die, die jetzt hier reingehört haben und etwas überrascht waren, was hier die Methode ist. Chaosradio Express, der Interview-Podcast wird jetzt hier in den nächsten Wochen noch dreimal aufschlagen. Jeweils sonntags 15 bis 17 Uhr auf Funkwelle FM. Und ich sage danke, Gregor, für die ausführlichen Ausführungen.
Danke, Tim, für deine Geduld.
Ja, ich hab Geduld. Und ich bin immer gespannt, was du mir Neues zu erzählen hast. Also das war's, bis bald und tschüss bei Chaosradio Express.